we have to start today with something so
important and of such consequence but
which regularly generates almost no
interest from our audience which is
foreign policy and what's going on right
now with russia and ukraine as we've
been covering and as many of you
uh have been seeing on a variety of
different media outlets
russia has been massing troops at the
border with ukraine now even that
statement is questioned by some who want
to defend putin
or
claim that that's all a lie for the
purposes of furthering american
imperialism or whatever um we're gonna
have a real hard time having any
conversation if we can't even agree on
the the fundamentals but that's going on
and now the discussion is among the
united states as well as other nato
allies
about if when and how
to mobilize military resources to nato
allies surrounding ukraine remembering
that ukraine is not part of nato and
that's a piece of this as well
with the question of
what would happen with those troops if
indeed russia did push into ukraine and
what would be russia's reason for doing
so when does vladimir putin really plan
to do that or is he only making it
appear as though he might plan to do
that so the latest news is that the
pentagon has put 8 500 troops on what
they are calling heightened alert
and that um joe biden was presented with
a number of options including moving
troops and equipment from other parts of
europe into poland romania and other
neighboring countries to ukraine again
remembering that ukraine itself is not a
nato ally the u.s is discussing the
deployment of military forces to eastern
europe with nato allies lloyd austin has
played placed 8 500 troops on heightened
alert to assist with the defense of nato
allies we have a clip of that uh here is
john kirby the spokesperson from the
pentagon
i want to provide some facts on these
preparations that will reinforce our
commitment to nato and to the nato
response force and increase our
readiness
secretary austin has placed a range of
units in the united states on a
heightened preparedness to deploy which
increases our readiness to provide
forces if nato should activate the nrf
or if other situations develop
all told
the number of forces that the secretary
has placed on heightened alert
comes up to about 8500 personnel so we
don't know what's going to happen yet
there are all sorts of different
speculations which quite frankly aren't
super interesting to me because we just
don't know what vladimir putin is
thinking but one of the most interesting
aspects of this is how different
political factions in the u.s have
responded as many of you now probably
know
on the
trump right
there is indeed
a pro-putin pro-russia
wing
which
developed under trump and it came in
part from trump's sort of deference to
vladimir putin for lack of a better term
not saying putin is a puppet master of
trump in any uh direct way i'm not
saying they colluded together to figure
you don't have to believe any of that
stuff that that's not what i'm saying
trump has been enamored with strong man
authoritarian dictator types he talked
about how he and kim jong-un fell in
love i might even have that clip we fell
in love and then we fell in love exactly
um you guys know all this stuff and to
that end
um we have seen a lot of these trumpists
kind of become enamored similarly with
putin and russia
similarly there are some on the left
what i tend to call
here we go the revolutionary left
the stalinist leninist
left and that's l-e-n-i-n by the way
some of you write to me and spell lenin
like john lennon and i'm wondering like
who do these who do they think i'm
referring to when i say leninist anyway
uh there's some there as well
who
have become very deferential to russia
usually they are sort of pro chavez
maduro types often they like fidel
castro
uh sometimes their views on syria are
sort of strange so there's that group as
well but one of the really interesting
things is that there's kind of a factual
firewall that seems to be plaguing some
where yesterday i saw for example
why is it
that tucker
saying we should be loyal to russia is
not okay
but democrats saying we should be loyal
to ukraine is okay like either way
you're just kind of picking aside
and of course i'm not picking any sides
i'm against aggression
and i'm against strongmen authoritarians
in this particular case
it's putin massing the troops at the
border with ukraine it is not ukraine
massing troops at the border with russia
and
throwing signals as if they might invade
russia so you can have any analysis that
makes sense to you you can have a
particular predilection for russia or
ukraine and quite frankly i i don't
but to say it's sort of the same when
one side clearly is the one at least
feigning aggression if not actually
planning to carry it out is not a very
sensible analysis so now there's going
to be some wait and see and if anybody
is going to write in and say david you
imperialist bastard wanting us
i don't want
any aggression i don't want any invasion
i don't want any war
i don't want troop deployment i don't i
don't want any of it i i think it's all
bad and it and i'm selfishly of that
opinion
i want stable economies
what's happening in the stock market
almost daily is not pleasing to me and i
think it would only get worse if these
escalations were so i'm against all of
it i don't want the us invading anybody
or anything like that now once you
understand the dynamics of ukraine not
even being in nato and the discussion
with biden and nato allies is about the
defense of nato allies in the area
you understand that that conversation
isn't even the appropriate one to be
having but that's what's going on we may
know more within a day
we may know more within
weeks could be months we just don't know
one of our sponsors is cometier coffee
cometeer coffee is delicious i can tell
you firsthand and they've discovered the
best way to brew preserve and deliver
coffee their brewing process captures
over two thousand flavor compounds
then the coffee is flash frozen locking
in the flavor it arrives at your home
frozen in a fully recyclable capsule all
you have to do is melt it by adding hot
water or cold water for iced coffee it
takes seconds it's the most convenient
way that i have ever made coffee i've
been impressed with how the process
protects the flavor i really enjoy
cometier they have a variety of flavor
options light medium and dark single
origin and blended coffee roasts from
the best specialty roasters you'll get
twenty dollars off when you go to
cometeer.com pacman the link is
underneath this video